michel rocard va jouer à quitte ou
double c'est le 19 novembre prochain que
le grand débat sur la motion de censure
pour la csg déjà programmées cet
après-midi le premier chouette premier
ministre a choisi le ton de la
détermination les derniers pointages à
l'assemblée le donnent gagnant mais rien
n'est encore joué il reste aussi tous
les budgets mis en réserve et qui
pourrait passer en bloc grâce aux 49 3
christian metz
ambiance de répétition générale pour
michel rocard cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale à une semaine de
l'examen de son projet de contribution
sociale généralisée
le premier ministre a pu se faire une
idée de l'état de mobilisation des
nombreux adversaires de la série cieux à
gauche d'abord avec le pc qui lui en
demandait le retrait réponse ironique le
ferment du premier ministre non monsieur
vokey je ne vais pas retirer le projet
de contribution sociale généralisée
csg fort loin de ressembler à
l'épouvantable caricature que vous en
faites
elle est une mesure de justice sociale
de solidarité
et elle apporte dans le fonctionnement
de la sécurité sociale un peu plus de
démocratie par la délibération annuel de
cette assemblée sur une partie de
l'opposition de son côté verrouille ses
rangs en vue du vote d'une motion de
censure une opération qui malgré
quelques grincements de dents centristes
ne devrait pas poser de problèmes
majeurs même philippe seguin
initialement favorable à une forme de
csg s'oppose vivement aux modalités du
projet rocard
ils pensent davantage à gérer son image
de présidentiable qui a gouverné
véritablement ce pays là la vérité il ya
un problème d'insécurité sociale la csg
une véritable scène j'ai peut être une
réponse à ce problème de la sécurité
sociale et on nous présente une espèce
d'importance dont on nous explique que
ça pour effet pour quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes de leur faire
économiser 40 de francs par mois on est
loin du grand débat de la grande affaire
dont il devrait dans le mois de
questions grandes ou petites la sphère
csg se retrouvera pour de bon cette fois
devant l'assemblée nationale jeudi
prochain le 15